as you say you do do breakdancing were
you able to break dance before or did
you learn for this
i was able to break dance before and
i've kind of um i can break dance less
now because it's not a skill i mean is
it a skill you've
kept up it's kind of i mean really
well okay i'm going to stand up i'm
going to stand up and pull can i do this
are you doing it yes
yes but don't spin around because sweat
will fly off and hit us all
it'll be just wrong no but but break
dancing is the stuff you do on the floor
okay so body popping is the stuff you do
when you're standing up
so when we started i was about 13 14 in
birmingham right
the body popping started with kind of
mine
we would do things like this yeah and
that was kind of oh
then it moved into robotics which
everyone knows what robotics is
you know that kind of it's a robot and
then and then you get electric boogaloo
which is where you chase a
ball of energy around your body so you
get you get things like that
[Applause]
[Music]
you